[Music]
the english riviera
is open for summer as the school
holidays begin the tourists have arrived
28 000 of them a night
but the restaurants hotels and
attractions here
have got a serious problem we've got a
crisis
um it's it's a crisis um that has come
now with within what is a critical
summer for us
it is resulting in extreme
earth shortage of staff so it's having a
devastating impact which is forcing for
many business to actually close
in high season it is the perfect storm
a staycation boom and an ever-increasing
number of workers
having to isolate after being pinged
on torquey marina whisup is known for
its food
but isolating staff mean the kitchen is
closed
our customers are so confused they the
government
and all the media is telling us that
we're coming out of lockdown hurrah
but actually they come to a premise like
ours and it feels worse than ever we've
got
no no opportunity to supply the product
that we're supposed to sell
big money is being lost with tourism in
torbay
worth more than half a billion pounds a
year
devon is expecting a 20 increase
in tourist numbers this year staff being
pinged
isn't just an issue for the cafes and
the restaurants it's the whole
tourism industry that is struggling to
provide a service
in what could be a record year
underneath torbay three staff at kent's
cabin have been pinged
while isolation rules may change next
month
bosses say it needs to happen now 45
percent of my business happens in five
weeks
and and and if we wait till the 16th of
august that's too late
at babicum theatre the summer show is
ready
but they've had to cancel all
performances this week
the whole cast is having to isolate we
were so looking forward to
the to the freedom that this week was
going to bring us
uh and the cast who've not been earning
for
for nearly 18 months we've had to turn
hundreds away this week who'd already
booked
so great disappointment all round the
industry here is calling on the
government to introduce a test and
release system instead
as businesses try to make hay while the
sun shines
rising cases and the very technology
protecting us
and making a summer recovery an even
bigger challenge
dan white said sky news in torbay